first of all I'm thrilled that you're
here I love that I'm talking to you and
I was telling you just before we started
recording that my daughter Nev is an
insane massive fan interestingly this
Story begins a number of months ago when
my daughter says I want you to come with
me to Coachella and I say sure that's
just the place for someone my age right
so we start driving and my daughter did
a really cool thing she didn't tell me
who the bands were but she started
playing me on the long drive she started
playing me all this different music and
saying you tell me who you think we
should go see when we're there she's
playing me all different kinds of music
and I'm saying I like this one I like
that band yeah this one should be good
and then I singled out
she played me a couple songs and they
said this is the band we have to see we
have to see this band and she said
correct that is Japanese breakfast
that's amazing yeah she sort of said it
like there's hope for this old fool
then we get to Coachella and she's
played me so much of your music that I'm
excited to see you and we go to your
tent show and you come out and you're
performing and I think you're playing
the song paprika and there's a gong on
stage a small gong and you know I'm
someone who loves to be on stage and I
can tell when someone else loves to be
on stage you come out you're kicking ass
I love your music you're playing this on
paprika and it's so joyous and you keep
you you keep running over and hitting a
Gong and I had never seen anybody do
that before and then you're back to
playing a song and then you rush over
and hit the gong again and I was I'm in
the crowd and I'm saying Tim yelling at
my daughter gong that's genius yes
why didn't I do that
years when I was doing a monologue every
night at night I should have said like
yeah I'm more like Donald Trump and then
run over and hit a gun yeah why didn't I
do that I don't know it's very cathartic
I I highly recommend writing it and I
want a Gong at the next live podcast
recording you'll just have a Gong next
to you and the cool thing is it's not a
giant gong it's a small it's a smaller
gong that makes like a crashing sound
right I don't feel like it's that small
well it's not the gongs I'm thinking of
are the ones that are like behind the
who yes exactly like Keith Moon would
get up at the end run over and hit and
would be like gone and it was kind of uh
kind of a joke I guess yeah yeah it's
not small but uh yeah don't call my
gongs sorry I'm sorry sorry it's a
sizable gone wow Michelle is walking out
of the interview yeah what happened what
did you say
said the gong seemed kind of small to me
you did what you gong shamed her I gong
shamed you
it's the worst thing you can do and then
I was just talking to you I just
mentioned that and you said you saw me
in the crowd I do stick out yes yes
you're very tall it's like Big Bird from
Sesame Street check out your set it was
hard to not just like look at you when
we were playing because we were all just
like oh my God Conan o'bri's like
watching us play and so I felt like I
like really had to perform for you and I
feel like I was just like watching you
and like hoping that you didn't like
walk away right uh that was like my
marker yeah but then looking in
retrospect I feel like that must have
been uncomfortable to be like someone's
focal point you stood in the middle of
the crowd no there's like a VIP area on
the side but you weren't like blocking
people behind because you I don't want
you to be the tall guy in the audience
just like blocking everyone behind why
do you always have to go negative Why
Can't This just be a joyous experience
when I'm hearing tall guy in the crowd I
just think those poor people behind you
yeah but this is the issue like how tall
is your daughter my daughter is not
and crushed crushed 11 people
I just got really excited and I jumped
up and it turned out they were all about
19 and they just buckle and small yeah
and they all buckled and and also they
were like why you just ruined Japanese
breakfast for us we all have to go to
the hospital now oh no yeah did you try
starting a mosh pit I tried that too I
threw stuff on stage and I kept hoping
that Michelle would call me up on stage
to sing one of my numbers oh about
growing up you know lonely and sad in
Boston but you didn't I know there is so
much to talk about I loved your show and
I've been really loving your music and I
love you direct a lot of your videos if
not all your videos you're so creative
in so many different ways and I'm I've
just gets me excited I love I love
meeting young people that are hyper
creative it makes me happy about the
future yeah yeah I know you you like
have your hand in a lot of different
things it's I I can never do that that's
not true you wrote a book she wrote a
book called world's worst assistant
which she truthfully uh wait really I
did and I'm I'm his assistant so it was
all about how bad I am working for him
and then he wrote the forward I wrote
the forward that's so cute yeah yeah
I've had people come up to me holding
the book because it did really well I've
had people come up to me holding the
book and they've said to me hey Connor
are you okay with this like she did it
behind my back and I said I wrote the
forward